- This one's (bleep) good.
("Amor Do Reggae")
I'm excited to have some Macca's.
- Bam.
("Amor Do Reggae")
This sort of looks like
a breakfast burger.
- OK.
- It's a basic burger.
- It's pretty standard McDonald's.
- I feel like this is
a burger that I'd maybe
keep in my pocket and save it for later.
- Bacon's a bit different.
- This is not bacon.
This is ham.
- Nothing's like American bacon.
I mean, you want the thin slices.
You know, the thick's good,
but it's like Canadian style.
- I just can't get around it.
- Sorry, but I don't think this is bacon.
("Amor Do Reggae")
It's a nice fancy bun.
- Like an everything bagel.
- It's a pretty big burger.
- There seems to be a lot
of ketchup oozing out.
- A painting of ketchup on here.
- Mmmm.
- That's pretty good.
- The meat to bun ratio
on this is on point.
- There's actually a lot going on here.
- The sauce was very surprising tasting.
It kind of just like spurted
out the Mighty Angus.
- It's more barbecue-y, and hearty,
and like nothing they
would have in the US.
- It sort of tastes like a cheese steak.
- The condiments and onions
are giving me a little
bit of a meatloaf vibe.
- This is the meal you want at three am
when all the bars close.
- Definitely not what I remember
from being six years old
and getting a Big Mac.
("Amor Do Reggae")
- It looks kind of like a Big Mac,
but a lot smaller.
- Lots of toppings.
- Looks pretty good.
- The amount of vegetables
on this is commendable.
- Almost like your dollar
menu American burger.
- It's like a quarter pounder with mayo.
- So if Big Mac had a little cousin,
this would be it.
("Amor Do Reggae")
- Maybe it was just a dream,
but I feel at one time they
had frozen Coke in the US.
- Here we go.
- Woah.
It's chunky.
- It doesn't taste like
the Coke I'm used to.
- Frozen Coke definitely
is better than normal Coke
'cause then you don't even
have to worry about the ice.
You don't have to worry about
it watering down your drink.
- And I wish they had
frozen Coke in the US
'cause then I could sneak it
into the movie theater with me.
("Amor Do Reggae")
- I'm actually from the southwest.
And when you hand a
Texan a southwest burger,
it better be legitimate.
- Stacking it nice and high
with all those toppings.
- When the hell did
McDonald's get so fancy?
- Oh.
- It's got some like Big Mac sauce.
What is that?
- Almost like Taco Bell sauce.
- Tastes like a collaboration
between McDonald's
and Taco Bell.
- What?
- Nacho chips?
- Is that a corn chip?
- The chips just add a
really weird texture,
like it's almost dangerous.
- I'm into it.
- I think the southwest
is almost like this
Cajun spicy like herbs that go on it.
- I mean, it's good flavor.
Don't get me wrong, it's a good burger,
but I don't think it has anything to do
with the southwest.
- This one's (bleep) good.
I like this one.
("Amor Do Reggae")
- Macca's is just a cool name.